the supreme court has overturned roe
versus wade it's historic no doubt about
it they have eliminated the
constitutional right to an abortion it
is a momentous decision now attention
has turned to abortion pills medical
abortions or pill-based abortions have
been on the rise since the turn of the
century and data suggests that they now
account for more than half of abortions
in the u.s but how do these pills work
are there any side effects and what's
the outlook for medical abortions in a
post-rural world i'll
explain abortion pills which are used
for medical abortions are actually two
medications methopristone and
misoprostol and together they work to
terminate a pregnancy
as you can see searches for medical
abortion mythoprestone and misoprostol
surged in the days following the supreme
court's decision the food and drug
administration has approved medical
abortions for up to 10 weeks of
pregnancy
doctors start that clock from the first
day of a woman's last period which means
that the clock starts before conception
so how do you get abortion pills well
they require a prescription until
recently the fda required a patient to
pick up mr pristone in person at a
credentialed doctor's office but the
agency lifted that rule permanently in
december 2021 allowing abortion pills to
be sent by mail
still
28 states require at least one in-person
appointment for a patient to get a
medical abortion so how do abortion
pills work myth pristone is the first
pill taken this medication blocks a
hormone called progesterone which is
necessary for a pregnancy to progress
next a patient usually takes four
misophostol pills at once that usually
happens at home
misoprostol helps soften the cervix a
structure at the base of the uterus that
clamshell during pregnancy to keep an
embryo or a fetus inside it also causes
contractions which helps to clear the
uterus misoprostol mimics a fatty
hormone-like substance called
prostaglandin e1 it controls processes
like inflammation and the induction of
labor and is sometimes used to treat
erectile dysfunction
misoprostol can be easier to get than
methapristone that's because it's used
for a wider range of conditions for
instance following a miscarriage or for
certain gastrointestinal problems
bleeding cramping and the expulsion of
tissue usually happens within four hours
of taking the pills
when mythic pristone and misoprostol are
taken together up to 10 weeks of
pregnancy the efficacy rate is 95
if taken later which some countries do
allow the efficacy rates are lower if
the initial regimen doesn't work a
patient could get a second round of
misoprostol or if needed a surgical
abortion
research shows that medical abortions
are safe for patients for instance
studies have shown the two medication
abortion regimen to be safer than widely
used drugs including acetaminophen
penicillin and viagra according to a
paper in the journal contraception major
complications requiring either
hospitalization or a blood transfusion
happen in less than 0.4 percent of cases
among the roughly 5 million women
estimated to have used mifapristone to
terminate a pregnancy 26 died according
to fda data collected through june 2021
other research estimates that the risk
of death from a medical abortion in the
u.s is one in a hundred thousand
compared to one in ten thousand for live
births common side effects include
nausea vomiting diarrhea dizziness and
headaches but doctors say these symptoms
usually resolve within a day or two they
also told me that a major misconception
was that having a medical abortion could
affect your fertility or increase your
risk for breast cancer in the future
they said that there is no evidence for
that but doctors say that if a patient
has an ectopic pregnancy where
fertilized egg attaches outside the
uterus they shouldn't have a medical
abortion another misconception is that
the authorities could differentiate
between a medical abortion and a
miscarriage but doctors said there isn't
a test to tell the difference between
the two
so what happens to medical abortions
after the supreme court's decision
about half of the states are expected to
ban or severely limit access to abortion
including medical abortions doctors say
they expect demand to rise but there are
questions about whether clinicians and
patients could face criminal charges for
providing or using abortion pills in
states where abortion isn't legal
for instance tennessee criminalized
distributors who send abortion pills by
mail south dakota is restricting medical
abortions via telemedicine starting july
1st in louisiana's ban on mail order
abortion pills it starts august 1st a
medical abortion can cost up to 750
whether it's covered by insurance
depends on the state a patient lives in
and their insurance only 16 states cover
abortion costs through medicaid which
covers healthcare costs for low-income
people for people with private insurance
employers are already trying to figure
out whether and how to pay for employees
to travel to states where abortions are
legal because ordering online from
international vendors doesn't require a
prescription doctors expect patients to
turn to the internet for access they
worry that patients might end up buying
abortion pills from disreputable sources
which could be dangerous and some states
are looking to amend their state
constitutions to protect abortion rights
that's another signal that access will
vary a lot depending on where you live